now all of these major developments into
all the things we're talking about will
be the subject of Investigations in the
republican-controlled Congress as of
January as top GOP lawmakers now are
vowing to conduct oversight and expose
the failings of major tech companies and
top government institutions like the FBI
to hold Bad actors accountable here to
explain more Congressman James Comer he
will be investigating the bidens in the
Judiciary Committee Jim Jordan he will
be investigating whether or not our FBI
is politicized and Department of Justice
is weaponized Congressman Comer I'll
begin with you now that we know the FBI
had this laptop for 11 months there are
there's low hanging fruit crimes but
that's not the big one the you said when
you made your announcement about your
investigation this is an investigation
into the president of the United States
that laptop implicates Joe Biden we have
photographs that prove that he was with
Hunter here and his farm business
associates we know that he went and
attended meetings with Farm business
associates and Hunter we know Hunter
[ __ ] and moans and groans and
complains he's paying dad or pops all
this money so the question here is is
this the biggest influence peddling
Scandal Congress is investigating
absolutely there's nothing like it in
the history of America we've never had a
family that has influence peddled to
this degree and if you look at the the
whole purpose of what we're talking
about today it's because this
investigation of the Biden family
influence peddling the evidence is based
a lot in part with what the documents
are and the data is on the laptop so
Sean I'm breaking on your show tonight
based on the internal documents that
Elon Musk released this weekend the
oversight committee will be sending a
letter tomorrow morning to the three
Twitter employees Miss Gaddy Roth and
Baker that were implicated in the
cover-up of the laptop Story three
letters requesting their presence in
front of the oversight Committee in
January but but wasn't the FBI putting
pressure on big tech companies oh you
yeah they're going to try go ahead sir
right and and what what we're going to
ask them is who was influencing your
decision banking did you do this
unilaterally or did you do this based on
uh what you were told from the Biden
campaign from the Democrat National
Committee or even worse and as I suspect
from the FBI this is going to be an
opportunity for the American people to
hear directly from the three Twitter
employees implicated in the data release
that that Elon Musk just dumped this
weekend so they're going to have a few
weeks to get their stories straight and
they're going to be able to come under
oath in front of the house oversight
committee and tell the American people
what really happened and why why were
they so intent on suppressing this story
and Jim Jordan as the head of Judiciary
your investigation will be working in
tandem with Congressman Comer because
you're looking into whether or not based
on whistleblower testimony among other
things whether or not our FBI has been
politicized and our department of
justice weaponized uh what is your take
on the fact that they will had weekly
meetings warning these big tech
companies oh be on the lookout uh
they're probably going to give you hack
materials some of it may be about Hunter
Biden were they trying to prevent big
Tech from letting that story go out why
didn't they do anything for the 11
months that they had the laptop
themselves they could have been
investigating all of this
so Sean the answer to your question who
at the FBI was responsible for
suppressing this story and going and
briefing these big Tech platforms the
answer to Clay's question who is that
key person we know where to start
Timothy t-bolt that's where you start
because a whistleblower FBI agent as a
whistleblower went to Senator Grassley
and said this is the guy who was pushing
to suppress the hunter Biden story his
name also came up with a different
whistleblower who came to us so the
place you start is with Timothy Tebow to
get the answers but here's the key fact
the guy that that Jim Baker that Mr
Comer just mentioned that's the key
because Jim Baker was the chief counsel
at the FBI back when they spied on
President Trump's campaign and then Jim
Baker Shazam goes to Twitter and is
their general counsel and is the one who
did the email saying well it's
reasonable to assume that this is a
hacking operation and therefore we can
we can throttle back the story about the
hunter Biden laptop so that's where you
start right Jim Baker and Timothy t-ball
and we have been trying to get Mr t-bolt
in for a deposition we will make sure
that happens in January Jamie's already
working on Mr Baker that's how you get
to the bottom of this and the way you
stop it is to get the facts everything
out there like Elon Musk has started but
we're going to continue you get the
facts out there that's the first step
into making sure this kind of baloney
and garbage never happens again Jim
Jordan is Elon Musk right when he says
that when you shut down dissenting
voices that is by very definition
election interference do you agree that
the media was complicit in lying to the
American public uh and acting as the
propaganda arm of the democratic party
and do you believe that the FBI is
behind all that pressure to prevent big
Tech from publishing that story to help
Joe Biden get elected
yeah it sure looks because remember the
51 former Intel official send a letter
says it says all the classic earmarks of
a Russian disinformation operation the
real disinformation operation was the
one the FBI and big Tech were running on
the American people and Jim Baker was at
the heart of it so let's get him in here
to talk to Jamie and his team and then
we'll get Timothy t-ball into the
Judiciary Committee talk to him and get
to the bottom of it as I said so we get
the facts to the American people Jim
coma we'll give you the last word
tonight
well remember Sean the whole purpose of
this investigation is to determine
whether or not this White House is
compromised when you look at all the bad
policies coming out of this white house
especially with respect to things like
energy policy and the fact that Biden's
trying to embrace this green New Deal
who wants the Green New Deal more than
anyone other than a few liberals in
California China they want to put us in
a competitive disadvantage so a lot of
the bad decisions this Administration is
making may be because they're
compromised because of the millions of
dollars that they've received through
influence peddling from our adversaries
in China Russia and the Middle East
that's why we're investigating the Biden
family and that's why we're going to
kick into high gear in January once we
have subpoena power and the gavel and
you are investigating the president as
of the United States for influence
peddling is that correct
absolutely that is the investigation yes
sir Congressman James Comer thank you
Congressman Jim Jordan thank you also
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else